I love being back in Denver where you
have legalized recreational marijuana I
thank you for being pioneers in that
where are the drinkers tonight though
where are you at what's up balcony
what's up up there in the balcony and
the weed smokers where are you that's me
I'm a weed smoker now I don't smoke
daily but I do smoke nightly okay and I
have a drink every now and then too but
just for me like I had to really assess
alcohols role in my life you know I'm
when I'm just comparing the two just
alcohol and weed for me alcohol has
always been the bad guy it's always been
full of shitty decisions it's never had
my back it's just been a really bad
friend weed has been the good guy
weeds been there for me weeds been kind
gentle caring we will humble me if
necessary okay weeds been a good friend
I've been smoking weed for 25 years and
in that 25 years weeds never told me to
do some of the [ __ ] alcohols told me to
do 25 years not one time ever Denver not
one time ever has weed said to me just
go ahead and piss yourself right here
it's fine
nobody's even gonna notice that is
terrible advice alcohol everyone's gonna
[ __ ] notice we would never say that
to me no we would say to me Ryan your
five-year-old daughter doesn't piss
herself get your [ __ ] dick behind a
dumpster and get your goddamn life
together but all right we chin okay when
you're right you're right we we'd help
me out with a very serious situation
recently I'm a single dad and I had to
go meet my daughter's mother's new
boyfriend okay and he's a cop all right
he's a chip remember chips remember
chips I got to go meet punch okay this
is my life and I'm telling some friends
about it now like man you should have a
couple beers before you go over there
have a shot I was like I'm not taking
that [ __ ] alcohol over there with me
no way I want to be the best
representation of myself not just for me
but for me and my daughter we're a team
I want the two of us to look good I'm
not drinking before I meet this guy I'm
smoking weed before I meet his ass and
I'm glad I did cuz when I got there and
I walked past his police cruiser and I
peeked in that window if I were to drank
alcohol alcohol would have said bust his
windows but I didn't drink alcohol I
smoked weed the good guy and when I
walked past his police cruiser looked in
the window you know weed said hey man
tell him he left his interior light on
[Laughter]
nobody likes a dead battery Ryan if
we're gonna break this [ __ ] all the way
down
that's all our tax dollars at work well
[ __ ] we when you put it like that I
gotta say something that is our tax
dollars at work damn it up and over some
friends houses watching their favorite
sports team play their drinking I start
to see the team losing oh my gosh yeah
and the team loses and what do they do
they tear their house apart tear your
house apart you think we would ever let
you tear your home apart hell no no we
is gonna lay right next to you on the
couch root your favorite team on us say
[ __ ] to you like hey Ryan you know we
could use around here some holiday hand
towels
that's a good idea we'd spruce this
place up a little bit and we ain't done
there weeds like I ain't talking about
just Christmases [ __ ] man all the
holidays I said damn that's a great idea
I would love some Halloween hand towels
let's get those Jack and lanterns and
[ __ ] candy cords hanging off the oven
right now give me a Chanukah hand - I
don't even know where to get one but
damn and I want to be festively
appropriate but see alcohol is a dick
and you know what alcohol would say
alcohol would say let's wipe our ass on
those hand towels and weeds ready for
that
weeds ready to tell you hey man used to
Thanksgiving ones they're already brown
weave you thought I loved it weave you
thought everything I had to stop man I
was nights I would come home so [ __ ]
up I didn't know where I was I didn't
know how I was house getting in any
place and alcohol star chirp and talking
to me let's get the crowbar out the
truck will get in someplace like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about weed
would never encourage a B&E okay it's
not gonna happen
you know we would say to me in that
situation Ryan there's a spare key on at
a flower pot man we live here
thank you we we do live here and that is
where I keep the spare key under the
flowerpot you're a good goddamn friend
we the good guy we need to have you help
an old lady across the street alcohol
have you asked her out that's the
difference the other thing I love about
weeds is there's no [ __ ] hangover
there's no hangover we don't go out with
your party all night long
then weeds gonna come home it's gonna
come home with you it's gonna sleep with
you too it's gonna put you in bed pull
the covers up tuck in and then get in
and outside spoon yeah all night long
sleep peaceful is [ __ ] not alcohol nope
outlaws coming home but alcohol don't
even wanna sleep in the bed nope alcohol
wants to sleep in between the toilet in
the wall with your arm bent over your
[ __ ] of that while you're throwing your
goddamn guts up in the toilet all
[ __ ] night and then the top it off
alcohol wants a [ __ ] your night pants
weed ain't [ __ ] in your night pants you
wake up in the morning your head still
pounding like what the [ __ ] did I do
last night you don't remember anything
but here's the thing weeds up weeds been
up okay we'd already made breakfast we'd
had coffee we took that morning [ __ ] and
weeds out walking a dog smoking a joint
cuz that's how chilly it is it smokes
itself
Adrenaline's another thing the beautiful
thing about weed is it's not too
powerful all right adrenaline is
something that will override weed like
that okay everyone's always worried
about the cops that's what it always is
well if the cops show up we don't tell
you we duplicate cops are here
smoke bellator poof and it's gone it's
gone and you were right back to you that
moment not alcohol alcohol cops show up
alcohol start talking [ __ ] how godly how
many of Mizzy
i think we could take them if I see an
opening Ryan I'm going for his gun shut
the [ __ ] up we're not going for
anybody's gun alcohol shut the [ __ ] up
and alcohols a liar if you're drinking
tonight I want you to enjoy yourself
make sure you take care of that
waitstaff they're working hard for you
but get home safe cuz alcohol is a
[ __ ] liar alcohols a liar if you get
pulled over alcohol make you think you
can pass those tests you ain't passing
those [ __ ] tests you get pulled over
alcohol bag we got this [ __ ] I'm gonna
do a cartwheel down that double yellow
line I'm gonna hit him with a round off
at the end
show him who's boss let's [ __ ] do
this open that card or a poop facedown
right there just did all the work for
they're gonna come over your Cuffy and
tease you just for [ __ ] sport we would
never let me drive hai ever if I was
hide behind the wheel we would [ __ ]
get my ass big Ryan what the [ __ ] are
you doing pull over this is a great time
to catch up on some calls organize the
glovebox and figure out a fix the clock
on this [ __ ] radio like god
damn weed you're a good friend weed
you're a good friend done thought
everything we'd thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you